Venezuela se ha convertido en el amigo feo de los países hispanoparlantes, da igual
cómo esté tu país,
Venezuela está peor. Por eso, a los
medios de comunicación les encanta
mostrarnos imágenes de Caracas para
hacernos sentir que,
bueno, pues tampoco estamos tan mal. Y esa
es la razón por la cual en VisualPolitik
llevamos tanto tiempo evitando
la tentación de hablar de este país,
pese a que muchos de vosotros nos habéis
pedido que lo hagamos.
Pensábamos que como todos los medios
hablan de Venezuela es imposible aportar
algo nuevo,
sin embargo hay una cosa que casi nadie
se ha molestado en explicar todavía:
¿cómo han llegado hasta ahí? ¿qué ha
tenido que hacer Nicolás Maduro para
convertir el país con más reservas de
petróleo del mundo en un lugar en plena
bancarrota?
Hoy, te lo vamos a explicar.
Por si alguien no
lo sabe.
Hugo Chávez fue el anterior presidente
de Venezuela y padre de la revolución
bolivariana.
Una de sus primeras políticas fue el
llamado Sistema de Democratización del
Empleo que implementó en la empresa
PDVSA, que es la compañía estatal de
Venezuela encargada de extraer el
petróleo que tiene este país que como
hemos dicho es mucho más abundante que el de Arabia Saudí.
"La plantilla de
PDVSA se ha duplicado hasta llegar a
los 115.000 empleados desde que Chávez
llegó al poder".
En sólo cuatro años la
empresa más grande de Latinoamérica se
había multiplicado por cuatro. Sin
embargo, Venezuela seguía produciendo el
mismo número de barriles de petróleo
que antes. Es decir, que esta ampliación
de plantilla no se debía a criterios
empresariales sino simplemente a un
intento por parte del gobierno de crear
más empleos. En la administración
pública pasó tres cuartas de lo mismo:
el gasto público se multiplicó por
tres durante el gobierno de Hugo Chávez
eso significa muchísimos más
funcionarios y muchísimos más programas
de todo tipo.
Sin embargo, los ingresos por la
exportación de petróleo
justificaban todo, por eso es durante
estos años cuando Venezuela pasa de
tener un 60% de población
viviendo bajo el umbral de la pobreza a
tener solamente un 30%, y aunque Hugo Chávez se empeñará en decir que había
una conspiración de los países
occidentales por atacar a la revolución
bolivariana,
lo cierto es que nadie rechazaba el
petróleo de Venezuela y para muestra
aquí expongo una cita de Nicolás
Sarkozy, que por aquel entonces era el
presidente conservador de Francia.
"Me alegra el buen desarrollo del
escrutinio, marcado por una fuerte
participación que atestigua una vez
más la vitalidad de la democracia en
Venezuela".
Sin embargo, este tipo de políticas
unidas al famoso "exprópiese" terminaron
por hacer que Venezuela dependiera casi
en su totalidad del petróleo. En 2012
el 95% de las exportaciones de
este país eran crudo; a esto hay que
sumarle que como hemos visto PDVSA
tenía un coste muchísimo mayor que el
de cualquier otra petrolera del mundo.
Sin embargo siempre y cuando el precio
de mercado del barril fuera superior al
coste de extracción, Venezuela seguía
ingresando dinero. ¡Pero esperad un
momento, porque ahora viene la parte mala!
En el año 2014
los precios del petróleo caen en picado
y el primer país en notar los efectos
es Venezuela.
Para cuando empieza esta crisis
petrolera Hugo Chávez ya había muerto
y le había sucedido Nicolás Maduro
"Si tú silbas yo silbo, entonces silbé. El pajarito me vio raro, silbó un ratico me
dio una vuelta y se fue. Yo sentí el
espíritu de él. Lo sentí ahí como
dándonos una bendición". Maduro se encuentra
con que Venezuela ya no gana dinero con
su petróleo,
sin embargo todavía tienen muchos
sueldos que pagar. Eso unido a la
política del "exprópiese" hace que venezuela casi
no tenga empresas privadas con lo cual
aunque quisiera subir los impuestos y
recaudar no podría porque quién iba a
pagarlos. Por si esto fuera poco los
impuestos se cobran en bolívares que es
una moneda que cada vez vale menos.
Es decir, el gobierno no tenía ni dinero
ni capacidad de conseguirlo y en ese
momento es cuando Maduri toma una de
las peores decisiones que puede tomar un
político imprimir dinero para conseguir
liquidez.
Al devaluar el bolívar la inflación se
disparó, para que os hagáis una idea en
los tres meses de verano de 2015
los precios se duplicaron. Esto significa
que si tú estás en Caracas en el mes
de junio de 2015 y te tomás una cerveza
que te cuesta 50 bolívares vuelves tres
meses más tarde al mismo bar y la
misma cerveza te cuesta 100. Pues esto
es lo que está pasando en Venezuela
desde hace tres años.
Lógicamente todo esto dio al traste con
todas las misiones bolivarianas que
había creado Hugo Chávez para acabar
con la pobreza. y en este momento es
cuando Nicolás Maduro toma la decisión
que termina por reventar toda la
economía venezolana: "el nuevo intrumento
legal para regularizar toda esas actividades
económicas tiene que ver con la
creación del precio máximo de venta al
público".
En opinión de Maduro la inflación se
debía a la especulación de los
capitalistas; olvidaba que su
gobierno había sido el primero en
especular con su divisa. ¿Y cuál ha sido
el resultado, os preguntaréis? Imaginad
que tenéis una carnicería en Maracaibo y
vuestra proveedor está en Colombia y
expende la carne en dólares.
Vamos a poner por ejemplo que el kilo de
ternera está a 10 dólares. El tipo de
cambio que te da el Banco Central de
Venezuela es de 10 bolívares por
dólares pero en realidad nadie te va a
dar dólares a ese precio,
así que si quieres pagarle a tu
proveedor a lo mejor le tienes que dar
el equivalente a 10 mil bolívares.
Una vez has comprado la carne llegas a tu tienda en
Maracaibo y la quieres vender pero... ¡Ah!El
gobierno pone un control de precios y no
puedes vender más caro de mil
bolívares con lo cual no es ya que no
ganes beneficio es que estás en pérdidas.
¿Qué haces en este caso? Pues una de
dos o cierras la carnicería o intentas
colocar tu producto en el mercado negro.
Y alguno os preguntaréis, ¿y por qué tienen
que comprar productos en el extranjero?
Siguiendo mi ejemplo, ¿acaso no hay
ganaderos en Venezuela? La respuesta es
que cualquier producto que quieras
comprar necesita alguna herramienta o
alguna materia prima que se hace en el
extranjero. Por ejemplo, si quisieras
producir tu propio trigo en Venezuela
necesitarás la semillas, los
fertilizantes, el tractor... Alguna de esas
cosas
seguro que está hecha en otro país. A
día de hoy ningún país es capaz de
producir todo lo que consume, todos de
una forma u otra
necesitan comerciar con otros países y
más aún Venezuela que como hemos
dicho basaba toda su economía en un
único producto que era el petróleo y
ahora ni siquiera eso.
"Venezuela ha  lanzado su mayor oferta de compra:
quieren comprar más de 8 millones de
barriles de crudo a Estados Unidos o
Nigeria".
Como decíamos antes los costes de
producción de petróleo en Venezuela
son tan altos que les resulta más
rentable comprarlo a otros países que
producirlo en el suyo. Y todo esto es lo
que explica estas colas kilométricas
que vemos en los supermercados de
Caracas donde la gente se pega por un
rollo de papel higiénico.
Y ahora me toca preguntaros: ¿creéis que
Maduro es capaz de sacar al país de la
crisis en la que él mismo le ha metido?
¿Existe alguna alternativa política real
en Venezuela que nos pueda dar algo de
esperanza? Me podéis dejar vuestras
opiniones en los comentarios.
Como siempre si alguien quiere
profundizar más en este tema,
encontrarás varios links en la
descripción. Si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a "like" y suscribiros al
canal si no lo habéis hecho todavía.
¡Un saludo y hasta pronto!